i don't want to learn any more life
lessons my character is developed
go away
selena gomez is sick of that same old
adulting life
[Music]
and we completely relate cell oh my
goodness the 29 year old tick tock queen
posted a video lip syncing to a sound
where she jokingly airs out her
grievances about adulthood
i don't want to learn any more life
lessons my character is developed
go away
leave it to selena to always keep it
real with her fans about her daily
struggles even when she does it in a
funny way online i feel comfortable in
my skin you know i don't want to learn
any more life lessons my character is
developed
go away
so yeah cell might be over adulting but
we're over here taking notes because
she's leading by example i heard a
phrase actually recently that i really
like that which is mentionable becomes
manageable last week the singer who is a
mental health advocate joined first lady
dr jill biden at the white house for
their first ever youth action forum i
felt like once i found out
what was going on mentally i found that
it was there was more freedom for me to
be okay with what i had because i was
learning about it
but bringing attention to mental health
or media or just by talking about your
own journeys can help
it sets the example that it's a topic
that can and should be discussed freely
and without shame i'm constantly
somebody that likes to grow and feel
like all right what could i be better at
what could i do better at work
where could my confidence be stronger
and when she's not busy making a
difference she's running her empire
which includes her beauty line
today is
more of a natural day with the angled
brush which i like a bit of highlighter
she's also churning out new music
[Music]
and earlier this year she earned her
first grammy nom for best latin pop
album for her ep revelation i cried like
a little baby i was very excited
and i worked really hard on that project
so it was
a lovely surprise i'm very excited she's
also acting on her critically acclaimed
show only murders in the building do i
want to break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all his sounds
like an afternoon and when et spoke to
cell and her co-stars steve martin and
martin short earlier this month they
teased what's to come on season two
crime and murder yeah and murder
mixed with kind of an element of crime
death yes and death
permeates really funny and considering
this is the queen of tick tock we're
talking about here we had to know if
selena plans to get the acting legends
in on the fun first off i think it's a
much more easy flowing um
kinder community on tick tock uh i don't
know if they they get it so maybe one
day
we have no idea what you said i know one
thing's for sure selena definitely gets
it i don't want to learn any more life
lessons
my character is developed
go away
[Music]
you